I've never understood why we can't just
use our side of the armrest
you know like you just like use the edge
of it you know like you both make you
gay we're back it's you up with Nikki
Glaser we're in the middle of talking to
Pete League I want to just get to how
you met your girlfriend because you met
your girlfriend on a plane I think we
see you flying to see me and possibly
with the possible hookup yes scenario
and then between you okay so for any
listener doesn't know the history of me
and Pete Lee and then how this lovely
lady who's one of my best friends came
to be is that Pete Lee and I fell in
love when we I was 20 you were like 43
and he was my first love we fell in love
where I was on the road in Kansas City
he was on the road I lived there I was
doing a guest that he was featuring we
met we had a weekend together we fell in
love we had sex at the end of the
weekend which like we all know what
happens to that I've talked about it
already and first orgasm not a big deal
okay
so major deal to a woman like like so I
fell in love with him we were gonna be
together forever he had a girlfriend
back in New York who he was gonna break
up with and I was gonna move to New York
after I graduated college and go live
with him he never broke up with her he
chose her over me bachelor style he
loved us both apparently and and but
then I never talked to him I said when
he broke up with me I was like I'm never
gonna talk to you again and I didn't
talk to him for 11 ish years 11 ish
years and we were both doing comedy
would see each other never saw him
finally I started hating someone else
more than I hated you
it freed up space to be friends with you
because I was like I want him back in my
life he's he married that girl
yeah the way he'd made the right choice
at the time at the time it was it's like
war you know like it's everything's okay
until nothing's okay
and the marriage fell apart I became I
was elated to hear that news little
mermaids voice oh my god totally
it makes me evil how much I loved that
you were like in pain I loved it so then
so then I ended up and then Pete was
single I knew that but I didn't really
like care he what he reached out to be
like hey can we talk about what happened
10 I think was like 9 years at that
point you really we ran into each
other's sand it was awkward you brought
me on stage because we had never had to
interact at all and I went to the sand
one night and he was hosting and I was
like I'm on there so he has to say my
name I have to shake his ham I go
onstage I just go this is weird or what
what are you good this is not ideal this
is not ideal and then I just took the
mic I was like I am around and then I
got home yeah I had an email from
beeping like that was not ideal was the
subject this is not idea and then he
wrote it was like hey it's been a long
time I have a lot to tell you I made a
promise to my ex-wife that I would never
talk to you again like that I wouldn't
reach out to you which makes sense so I
never had a chance to like tell you how
I felt about it
and why I chose it and all this and I
would love to get coffee and like talk
about it and I was like no thanks
still hate you not ready for this is
enough closure like hello goodbye no
friendship yeah then um then I started
hating someone else with the same venom
that I hated you for 11 years almost and
and then one night I saw you at the
stand and we were in some interaction
with someone having a conversation and I
was like oh I want you would always be
talking to my friends and I couldn't
talk to them because you would be
talking to them and I had to like not
talk to you yeah so one night you were
talking to be honest and some people and
I just like remember you said something
funny and I looked at you because I was
involved in the conversation at this
point and um and I look to you and I was
like I don't like hate him anymore and I
was like that's so weird but yeah it
just like was this thing that was there
forever and it just wasn't I was like I
felt like an affection for him of like
not like ooh sparks but it was just like
huh Pete I miss you
yeah and and it was because I hated
someone else and I and I'm monogamous
with hate and I'm polyamorous with love
but I can only hate one man at a time I
think we should all do that I think we
should all pick one person in our lives
to hate yes you know and now I don't
even hate that guy anymore so I don't
know who I hate when you started to not
hate that guy anymore I was like yeah I
felt like a baseball player that's
having a bad season the way I'm gonna be
traded so am I telling is there anything
you'd like to interject at this point no
I first of all you've told it very
efficiently yeah I told it so many times
I'm just getting through just so we can
get readers
yeah so then um he writes me that then
that night I was like oh I want to be
friends with him again
then I was I think still in a
relationship at the time and then I
broke up with my boyfriend
I heard Pete Lee had broken up with the
girlfriend that he was with after his
marriage ended and I was like oh we're
both single he's someone I had sex with
before this would be an easy thing to
just like I need to get back on the
horse you know and I should just like
have casual sex with Pete lately like we
can like not like pursue a relationship
but like see what's there she was like
this is ideal this is so I wrote you and
was like hey let's get that coffee I'm
like ready to be friends or whatever it
was I said is this weird I know it's
you're the coolest what that's so it's
so insane
so that yeah so then I reached out to
him because my friend goes Oh Pete broke
up with this girl and I was like oh I
need to have sex and I'll write like I'm
ready to be friends with him I already
knew that and so I reached out to you
you were in LA at the time I knew you
were and I was like let's hang out and
you were like hey um I'm really busy and
I was like oh he's not single there's no
he would make time to hang out with me
if he were saying I just know yeah I
would have and whether or not you wanted
to sleep it's like we there was we have
a good friendship and um or like it was
it was always there that that chemistry
of like good like love you know and so I
was like I just sensed there's the the
girl still around and so you were like
I'm running sets for Fallon I'm working
on my Fallon set so I don't have any
free nights and I was like well I'm
taking the nights off of comedy so I
have no sets and I won't be seeing you
anywhere ever saying that really
believing it and then I got asked to do
this set last minute I was like I have
nothing to do tonight I walk in and
Pete's there with that girl and so I've
my lie is now like yeah it wasn't even
like and I had to walk by it was just
and and but we were like I was like hi
like I think I just like and then she
knew her from before you I was like
friends with the curb ex-boyfriend and
she iced me that night I was like oh
this isn't good
so I quickly left after my set cut - we
serve being friends again shortly for
that you were still with her and then
can I get in all this yeah I was at the
end and it was at the end of her and I
and things were rocky and and then Nicki
and I were like we were legitimately
just friends but I had her saved in my
phone as a different name I felt weird
you know there's a good feeling inside
isn't it yeah I go Pete we're really
like emotionally involved right Natalie
we were just like talking on the phone
all the time always friends nothing
nothing that your ex-girlfriend could
have overheard and been like you guys
like no zero perversion zero literally
zero but I go I have a feeling that she
doesn't know like I would only get to
talk to you when she wasn't around you
know like she didn't know but I just had
a feeling because she wasn't someone
that would be able to handle you having
a girlfriend as close as we were it's a
good way to say it and so I said I'm
gonna say where I go I have a feeling
that right now I'm in your phone not as
Nikki Glaser like it is and you were
like yeah you're you're not you're
you're yeah you're not you're saved as
my friend Josh Wade yeah and I like
still when Josh Wade texts me I'm like
Nikki it's really weird and so then I
was like you got this is gonna end
I got a pullout because you're getting
like the fun of like front like this
emotional support that I know you're not
getting in a relationship and I'm
providing that for you because she's not
nice and and so I'm gonna pull out so
I'll talk to you in two weeks when you
guys break up because there
no way that you're gonna be able to stay
with her without having me as your
friend like talking you through it the
table leg like I was a table leg and I
pulled it out cuz your table is now
gonna be on study two weeks later he's
like we broke up and I'm and I wrote
back ha ha ha you and then I called you
and you were crying
I called you like you called me I was
crying pathetically in a hotel in Iowa
which is even worse and that's about to
cry yeah and then Nikki was like she was
like where are you I'll come see you oh
boy I literally said I just gotta have a
relationship to do you want to have sex
with each other and project our feelings
about our exes onto each other
yeah I'll come I'll come find you so we
looked at her schedules I was like
you're in Chicago I could fly out there
I almost bought a ticket and then I was
like nah that's ridiculous you're gonna
be in LA in a couple weeks so then yeah
so I was I was like yeah I'm gonna be in
LA next weekend and like you were like
oh what for and I was like I just you
know stuff meetings when everybody was
to go see her and I couldn't admit that
because the cool guy stuff you know I'm
so cool and and then I'm flying there
that weekend and I sit down next to
Jamie on the plane randomly ran into
this girl on the plane randomly sit next
and we're sitting in the last row first
class the reason being tying us all
together we don't want to recline our
seats than anyone because we're both
nice people pleasers and yeah and so I
say hello to her and she and I was again
I'm gonna go to sleep Beauvoir bathroom
and then she like wraps her sweater
around her head and falls asleep cuz she
calls oh she does least sleeper she says
yeah and so she creates a cocoon around
her head so no one can see her ugly
sleep it's brilliant
it's also makes it dark which is quite
yeah yeah everything you're protected
everything so she so then we wake up
about two hours into the flight and I
start telling her like yeah I'm going to
see Nikki and like we were friends I
tell her the whole story I just you know
we just hold and and so she's like
rooting for us yeah you know and and I
remember like the next day his like we
got there you stayed the night at my
hotel nothing happened well I I got my I
got my dogs out for the night I was
like I'm going to Pete leaves I packed
my little bag I had just I had just
taped I was coming from the taping of
drop the mic which is a rap battle
competition another worst idea I ever
signed up I competed in a rap battle and
I and I rap taping and I had my car
serviced just take me straight to the
Roosevelt to go hang out with you we go
hang out and the thing we're missing is
we had lunch and I landed and then I
told you about her don't hurt I told you
about her which is like not a good move
but the reason why I told you about it
is because I was like we're friends and
I don't want to be dishonest but then
also you're like kind of a you know
and whatever so I was like sure yeah I
was like if there's anybody that would
be cool with me and meeting a girl that
I vibed with to be you and exactly
that's a good point yeah you are kind of
a I am I like hearing about guys I
like being into other women in them
being into them so that was a year I
didn't realize that was a move you were
doing but I wasn't really doing there
was we I was just like we're just
friends what of what are we doing it was
so weird it was it was just so I gotten
my dog I had already like had the night
off from the dogs I was far away from my
apartment and I go I we were just like
it was just hot we were like having fun
but it was like when are we gonna hook
up if at all you know that vibe yeah
yeah and I was just like Pete I gotta be
honest like I'm just feeling a friend
vibe yeah and you were like oh my God
thank God me too and we were both and I
go can I still spend the night cuz I
don't want to go back home can I just
sleep in the same bed and so we slept
next to each other as friends
I had my noise-canceling headphones in
my sleep mask he had his sleep apnea
machine on CPAP machine
I kept thinking the whole night like
like when's she gonna come over and make
a move
it would be great if you had like a
Darth Vader fetish and that was your way
of getting her yeah okay Pete Lee back
to you meeting the love of your life oh
yeah
so you're flew to LA you meet this girl
you're telling this girl about this
other girl that you're gonna meet that
yeah what was her advice to you what did
you what did you think about this girl
when you first saw her was there like I
mean you were obviously attracted to her
very attracted to her her eyes were just
like I was melting with her eyes and and
I remember thinking of the feeling I was
sorry laughs yeah right those eyes it's
crazy
she's pretty she's so pretty and she had
such a chill warm deep vibe and when she
talks like this like she just very like
it's just like earnest and like kind of
just she hears you and understood I said
this other day but one night I was
crying at the cellar because some guides
it's something and she just I didn't
even know her it was the first time I
met her and she reached across II was
like can I hold your hand and she held
my hand as I leapt into my hummus mm-hmm
and then later and it felt so nice and
I'm really uncomfortable with
hand-holding like I've never held hands
with boyfriends or any like it just
we've never held here my parents don't
hold me as a kid I just crossed the
street on my own and and I so I was like
oh oh hold your hand cuz she seems like
she knows that this is gonna help me and
I trust her and then she the thing that
killed me was later on she wrote me a
text that said thank you for letting me
hold your hand and I like wept when I
read that was so sweet cuz I was like
that was hard for me to do and she
acknowledged it it was so and I'm like
why is she thanking me she was gonna
putting me she's a goddamn angel
okay go yeah she's a magic person she
really is and like and so yes so then
like I just I felt such a deep
connection and like like when I left her
at the airport I missed her like like
like immediately and then we went on our
separate ways and like stayed in touch
via Instagram and you know just like I
remember the next day I was like yeah it
didn't work out below blah and then you
know we went back and forth and talked
about that and then just kind of stayed
in touch
like at a distance for a long time yeah
for a long long time and then yeah and
then like I was single and I was dating
and like like you and I were kind of
like I don't know how to say it like
like single together you know like it
would be like like awful date you know
come back talk to each other on the
phone kind of a thing like all the just
the the worst of the worst situations
then you always you always want what but
what about playing girl like what about
playing girl and then it turned out that
I LA when I landed that day and I told
you you looked at our Instagram and you
go you go you're like I think
something's there and first of all you
look alike you said that we look like
when two people look people are always
drawn to people who kind of look like
them and it's not an insult like you
look like a man or that you look like a
woman even though you kind of do that
was a joke but no like you you guys have
similar things similar features I have a
joke in my act where I can't ever lie to
her cuz she gonna open my phone with her
face you ever eat so much that your
phone doesn't recognize that was based
so much in a party that I like my phone
wouldn't unlock and I was like god what
are you doing like but so yes so her and
I like I remember when we finally came
back together and to meet up I like I
walked into the hotel lobby where she
was staying and like I just felt that
vibe like that energy again that deep
connection I'm like this is the person
you're supposed to be with but when I
first met her I like that was a few days
after I'd gotten out of that
relationship and I was like well anybody
you meet you're gonna vibe with them and
I didn't realize that like you could go
on you know 20 dates and you wouldn't
vibe with any of them and that was that
was such a special thing and a lot of
times I feel like people discount who I
like they'll meet the person they're
meant to be with right out of
relationship and they go but it's
probably just my out of a relationship
like everyone's because that does happen
and sometimes you can discredit those
actual true things and you need to come
back around to them later because you
don't yeah you acknowledge them for what
they are in the moment because you can't
because it's clouded yeah yes
yeah and it's it's it's so weird because
like I mean I said I told her I loved
her like right away and and then I had a
you know Miran Kagame yeah he told me
he's like pump the brakes
pump the brakes sister lesbian speed
there's gonna be a movie next you know
and I was like and I just kept telling
people like no no like like she's really
great in there like no you move fast
you're moving fast and and then people
now that they meet her they're like what
are you doing move faster what's
happening cuz yeah when she meets people
she like changes them yeah it's it's
insane
yeah and last night Elna even or we were
hung out lesson and we just talked about
Jamie after you guys left for like the
whole time just about how amazing she is
like people get it right away and it's
not and I'm not hyperbole like it is
there's some things like and I knew it
wouldn't win you guys finally like when
you were connected I was like oh this is
it like I felt it from your texts even
about her yeah yeah this is I was like
can I be your best man
you said that yeah I texted you sex with
a bunch of axes you wrote can I be your
best mate and and then I can't I
yeah you can't seriously you can and me
and your brother yeah you and Rob can be
co-best men best day is it's gonna be a
gender neutral ceremony but yeah I
remember I sent you a picture of us for
like very early on and you go oh my god
that looks like an engagement picture
and then I sent you like it was like one
of the first times that we were like
really hanging out and we were like
having sex like I sent you a picture of
us and like we were like just like like
in bed we'd shirts on and stuff in like
- it was - in bed those throws voodoo is
you lose like the filter on right
you're right like you're so in it you're
like people gotta see this and you go
you you wrote back okay dr. dad I gotta
set some boundaries here you go I feel
like I'm having a three-way with you too
like we can't wait to meet it like it
felt like that kind of vibe and I'm like
I don't like this I'm so happy for you
yeah the thing was like I was already
becoming friends with her through your
text like you'd be like Jamie said she
can't wait to meet you and I'm like I
can't wait to meet her and then I called
you once and you were in the cardigan
that was the first time we talked Jamie
was in the car when you guys were
driving on the way to something and I
think I just what way - what story was
that oh when there was a cap stuck in me
yes yeah yeah I know so
oh my god that's so weird yeah I
remember I was getting done with a run
and I called you and whenever I get done
with a run I've just run a lot so I'm
like and I'm like talking so fast and I
remember being like she's gonna think
I'm psycho and then I was talking about
Oh cuz I was like about Sully landing on
the Hudson because I was running along
the Hudson and I was like I'm right by
where Sully landed and I remember the
day Sully landed because that was the
day that my boyfriend found a weird cap
inside my vagina that was left by it I
mean it's like a crazy story but he was
it's weird please just finish this a
great story
oh my god I'm so sorry that this I'm
like really I hate that I so January
17th mm I got a hotel room I was in st.
Louis my boyfriend I both lived with our
parents at the time I was like we were
both like drunk and broke and I got us a
hotel room that night and I remember I
was waiting all day for him to get off
work he showed up we're having sex and
he goes what we just starting dating
like maybe a couple weeks in and he's
like what is that and I'm like what is
what and he's like I feel something
scraping my dick and I'm like what oh
I don't have an IUD or anything so
I was like
I was really offended and he's like I
swear to God and I was like were you
talking about and so that I reached
inside myself and I was like and he's
like I don't know I felt it for a while
I didn't want to say anything I'm like I
don't know what that is I'm really and I
was just like so embarrassed I'm getting
embarrassed right now even like I'm
reliving it because it was like I don't
put things in and so he my fingers
weren't long enough to get it out it was
so lodged up so he had longer fingers so
he slenderman's up and and
forceps it out it is a blue cap it looks
like a chapstick cap oh and you're dry
you thought that would fix it I did was
nowhere to be found
anyway I mean trying to make long story
short I pull it out I am like I don't
know what this is he's like yeah right
like what why would you have something
in you I'm like I don't know what it is
I kept it because I was like I'm gonna
figure this out I I don't I I call my
doctor him like is there any way you
could have left something in me and I'm
like I'm gonna make some money because
like this is bad malpractice sure and
then I got a lawyer and they're like are
you effective where you lose your health
of impacted at all and I'm like because
I went back to it was like I it would
have been a year that it was left in me
based on the last time I was at the
doctor and that's the only time things
are in my vagina
like things scheana right like when
they're doctors doing whatever willy
nilly and um
and so then I remember the lawyer being
like were you affected at all and I was
like mmm
I mean emotionally it was embarrassing
he's like maybe there's something there
but like probably not I was like damn it
so then like I convinced my boyfriend
the time that like he believed me I was
like truly don't know what it was it's
so weird I was gonna string it on a
necklace for his like for Valentine's
Day as a joke didn't ever do that
grateful that I didn't
and then um I I one night I was like
like I'm gonna Google blue cap vagina
and just see what pops up and sure
enough there was a girl that posted on a
message board I found a blue cap in my
vagina I don't know what it is
does anyone else have this found this
and there was a picture of it and it was
the same thing and I was like oh my god
I found my like Traveling Pants sister
yeah so I emailed her and I was like
girl I have this I took a picture of
mine I was like whee what is this and
she's like I don't know what it is
she lived in Des Moines I was supposed
to be in Des Moines the next weekend at
the funny bone and I go come to a show
I'll get you in she's like I'm not
interested she's my age and like a cool
girl I thought I was like wait cool girl
type of girl who has caps and she never
showed but she got weird about she was
like I think this is a government
conspiracy I think it's a camera I think
that doctors are doing some weird
night and I was like I don't know if I
believe that and so I kind of left it
alone a couple more years passed and I
was just like well well there's one girl
with the blue cap we still don't know
what it is doesn't have a serial number
on it's just a plastic chapstick cap lid
size thing and then I googled it one
more time years later and another thing
came up and was another girl in a
message board that said I found a blue
cap in my vagina and then there was a
response to it that said that's a
Monistat cap from a Monistat thing so I
had given myself like I guess I had a
yeast infection at one point which I I
didn't even remember ever having one it
literally was like I've never put any
like I don't remember having one but I
you know when you do a thing uh-huh
there's a cap they're supposed to take
off that many many bitches are
forgetting to take this cap off and I
did it to myself
and so I wrote back the Des Moines girl
to be like hey girl long time no talk
I'm not coming back to town any time
soon but I found out what the it's not
an alien government conspiracy like you
you and I are stupid and don't know how
that works and she was like no I still
think so I in the end I just didn't know
how to use a thing and it had a cap in
my vagina for a really long time and it
was gross and that's the story of the
cap that I told on the phone with you
the first time I met you
we're gonna talk to my mom and my mom
just is probably on the line listening
to all this I don't know if he knew
about this mom but now you do we'll be
back with more show after this
[Music]
you